we're gonna continue the conversation
about the life of Barbara Bush and a lot
more good evening from Washington I'm
Laura Ingraham and this is the Ingraham
angle and we begin this evening as I
said with a continuing coverage of the
passing of first lady barbara Bush the
former first lady died today at her home
in Houston as Shaun said at age 92 she
was one of only two women in US history
to be both the mother and the wife of a
u.s. president but Barbara Bush was
special in so many other ways she was
down to earth and also dignified she was
elegant and she was admired and she was
loved by Americans and politicians on
both sides of the aisle which doesn't
seem possible today tributes are pouring
in from family friends and others whose
lives she touched joining us tonight for
a look at the legacy of this remarkably
gracious and kind woman are Bret Baier
Newt Gingrich called Rove and Brit Hume
it is great to see all of you tonight on
this sad night but I want to start with
you Karl Rove what a life what a lady
it's the the tributes from everybody
from Bill Clinton to foreign leaders
Democrats liberals conservatives and
with today's politics it's it's kind of
refreshing all over again
to hear how many people loved her so
much you know a rather formidable
presence a woman of great character of
enormous values there's going to be a
big welcoming party I suspect for her
but I'm sure the authorities in heaven
are making certain that everybody is on
their best behavior because mrs. Bush
had an expectation that you're capable
of doing good things and she would let
you know if if she felt you were you you
could do a little bit more to achieve
what she thought was good possible for
me she was I I met her when I was 22 and
I have a smile that could light up a
room a warmth a respect for everyone fun
to be around brash smart is really smart
and and capable of many a time I saw her
like needle pointing and you'd think
that she was focused on the needlepoint
and then she didn't jekt into that
conversation you knew she'd been paying
attention to every single word that you
had been saying I was
supposed to have lunch with them two
weeks ago today and she went into the
hospital on Monday and she was she was a
remarkable presence and think about it
advisor to a president a husband her
husband who she loved dearly met him
when she was 16 fell in love with him
married together for nearly 76 years
married for 73 I mean really and really
remarkable Newt Gingrich it's hard to
match up that Newt Gingrich the the one
of the great things about her and
there's so many great things about her
is her she said she'd have a lot of
pretense like she when she was
commenting first about becoming the vice
president vice president why she said a
lot of fat white haired ladies who were
wrinkled are tickled pink about my
ascending to this role she's just so fun
she didn't like dye her hair shouldn't
get a facelift she's like I am Who I am
that is so refreshing today again I use
the word refreshing but it's just I love
it
well I think at one point she described
herself as the nation's grandmother and
I think that that sort of captured it
and she had I think at that point she
had like 25 point higher approval rating
than her husband and you know Clisson I
were talking earlier tonight about what
what a remarkable couple and also though
they Karl Carter right she was ferocious
when she was pleasant she was nice
she was hot but in terms of both her
husband and her sons but in terms of
both Jeb's campaign George w's campaign
there's no question she was prepared to
go all out and she was prepared to reach
out to every friend she had and she
wanted the family to do well and
adenosine a remarkable American family
but well first of all that love affair
was really a lot of who she was love
affair with HW Bush 41 and with her
family today we're told that HW held her
hand all day long on next to her and
that she was surrounded by family and he
was right next to her when she left the
earth so I think you're seeing this
family rally around each other it was a
big part of their life to be together
she said that was the most important
thing in her life and she gave a lot of
commencement addresses and one of them
in Wesley College said at the end of
your life you will never regret not
having past one more test not winning
one more verdict or not closing one more
deal
you will regret time not spent with a
husband a child a friend or a parent
that's for sure we we all think that in
our lives goes by really fast those are
the moments if we actually have another
moment from that same address at
Wellesley College Brit tiem I want you
to react to this let's watch I want to
offer a new legend the winner of the
hoop race will be the first to realize
her dream not society's dreams her own
personal dream who knows somewhere out
in this audience may even be someone who
will one day follow in my footsteps and
preside over the White House as the
president's spouse and I wish him well
and the crowd we cut the crowd ever the
crowd Brit went crazy it was controversy
though about her appearing but compared
to what it's like today that was 1990
and a Republican goes to a college today
it's a different you know reception but
they ended up loving her there they did
and she was someone that people I think
it wasn't it she was so cuddly because
she really wasn't cuddly she was warm
and she was friendly and she was
outgoing but but she had standards and
you knew it when you were around her I
mean I always felt that I better be on
my best behavior around her and and she
used to say you know I proposed her
devotion to family she used to say when
she was when she was first lady she used
to say what happens at your house is
more important than what happens in the
White House not a view often expressed
but one that at the time I think was was
was taken well and was very much like
her she was very focused on family her
family in particular but family values
in particular which may have fallen out
of favor to some extent but they never
did with her and at one point she said
I'm worried about parents who don't
parent just simple sayings that kind of
stay with you and Carl
there was another
moment where she was talking about among
the professional things that she did or
things as his first lady was her
literacy initiative that really took a
whole during George w's term let's watch
I decided that I wanted to do something
that would help George that would help
the most Americans possible with without
costing the government huge amounts of
money do you can go to a hospital and
read to children yeah you can do that or
yeah but I don't think many people thank
me for the literacy a little bit annoyed
by that what you don't blame her because
it's in every state
she raised tens of millions of dollars
gets famous authors like Newt Gingrich
and Bret Baier and to go and speak and
she said I'm never gonna pay you you're
doing it for free and everyone said you
bet I'm gonna do it for free missus but
no problem I love the literacy I think
she does not get enough credit for that
so important in its family literacy that
she said holds families together faith
family and literacy reading together
absolutely right this was a great
passion for her and the focus was it is
your responsibility as a parent or as a
friend or a family member to help
someone else learn to love to read and
to do so at an early age and and it's
remarkable to even today that the effort
goes on in a huge fashion I want to talk
though about quickly about one other
thing you may remember that moment and
when she was the first lady of the
United States where she went to the
hospital in Washington and held an AIDS
baby this was at a time when a lot of
people thought that aids could be
communicated by simply touching an
individual and so a lot of these aids
babies were lacking human contact and
she went and did that and it's because
she wanted to set an example and she
wanted to make it clear that we this is
one of the things this this woman she
may have worn fake pearls and she may
have had gray hair but she had a respect
for every single human being in which
she came in contact with and expected
other people to have that same kind of
mutual respect for every one of God's
creatures and every one of God's people
and I thought it was a powerful moment
when she
did that and in an emblematic of this
great and noble woman who served our
countries who very patriotic she loved
America deeply and cherished the great
values that we have in our freedoms and
wanted others to enjoy and and respect
them as well
and it she was part of the greatest
generation I mean she and story of their
romance of really deciding to get
married but then weight him going off to
war he the youngest naval pilot in World
War two shot down
luckily saved by an American submarine
there's a lot to their whole lifetime
then moving to Texas which back then for
them was a pretty radical move running
for Congress serving as head of the CIA
Minh everywhere he went she went
[Music]
Medellin Texas their house in Midland
Texas if you've ever been there is a
very modest yeah very I mean it's it's
paper-thin walls and at one point they
were living next door to the local
prostitute with whom they shared a
bathroom I mean this was the Wild West
frontier in the air late 40s and early
50s you know the surrogate woman from
yeah yeah and they don't usually do that
but the people who worked for the bushes
loved the bushes her secret service name
was tranquility her code name and she
had a certain touch as Britt said she
could be fiery and sharp witted she
really loved privacy and when she left
she was hurt in 92 when when Bush lost
she wanted to get back to private life
she told the story that she was in the
store and some lady came up to her and
said wait aren't you Barbara Bush and
she said oh no she's much older than me
and Britt there was a moment during the
2016 campaign that I mean we were just
howling at earlier with my producers
because mrs. Bush was talking about what
the country needs at this point let's
watch you think there's room for another
Bush in the White House I think this is
a great American country great country
and if we can't find more than two or
three families to run for high office
that's silly
we got Jeff running and jelly wait mom
what's going on here hilarium she was
lit she she was later to change her view
of that I don't you may recall I think
Laura and all this we should have a
particular thought for George HW Bush
tonight when I met him and covered his
campaign back in 1980 they had been
married already for 35 years and this
marriage has gone on for what 72 73
years whenever they were together as
others have noted but in recent years in
particular they're always holding hands
it was one of the great marriages of our
time and here he is as late as he is in
his life with all her maladies that he's
suffered having to endure this loss
we've all lost something tonight but he
most of all god bless him absolutely and
broken hearts across this country
tonight I thank you all so much for all
your reflections